amanda is with us in minneapolis hi
Amanda welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave how are you doing today better
than I deserve what's up so my husband
and I are working on the baby steps
right now but he co-signed for a
mortgage with his mother before we were
married I'm just conflicted
yeah I'm conflicted I'm not sure do we
add that on there right now it's I mean
it was almost foreclosed upon and then
she filed for bankruptcy so right now
it's protected because she's in
bankruptcy but I just don't know what to
do there so she's in a chapter 13
bankruptcy yeah paying payments how long
has she been in I think only about a
year now
no fear and so of course you quit your
husband quit getting any information
about the loan once once it went into
bankruptcy
correct correct yeah I had I had a call
to get that information now they're not
allowed to contact him as a cosigner if
she is in bankruptcy
they can't contact her either or they
have to everything through the courts
okay so they can't they can't just
passively let you know you have to
proactively check in and even then you
may file and even then you may find that
they are going to block you a little bit
because they're scared to the court
telling them not to talk to not to
bother a creditor a debtor okay anyway
so how much does she owe on this house
does he owe on this house 222 balance
what does mom make a year oh I'm not
sure it's got to be over 50 he's making
50 yeah so she doesn't make the money to
pay below for this house no she no
that's what got her in trouble didn't it
yeah so when is your husband going to
talk to his mom about selling the house
that she can't afford
we've had that conversation and ever
since then she's just decided that she
doesn't want to talk to us about it
anymore
so we aren't really in good standing
with her she just she believes that she
deserves a house and she's gonna she's
going to go down with it if it goes away
do you know what kind of loan it is FHA
VA or conventional I do not know I would
find that out okay okay I hope to god
it's an FHA because here's well here's
what's going to happen with the
information you've given me she's going
to default on the bankruptcy because
she's not gonna pay the payment she
couldn't pay the house payment outside
of bankruptcy inside of bankruptcy have
to pay the full payment plus something
on the back payments in order to keep
the bankruptcy Act if she's not going to
do that 78% of chapter 13s fail
nationwide so there's an 8 out of 10
probability she's gonna fail plus we
know what her situation is it's higher
than that she's gonna fail okay okay so
let's anticipate that let's not be
shocked that she didn't fail plus she
couldn't pay the payment start with so
she's struggling already it's a sad
situation okay now when she fails
they're going to kick her out of
bankruptcy and then the foreclosure is
going to begin again if it is H if it is
an FHA loan when they foreclose they do
not chase the borrowers for deficit
balance so the only thing that will
happen to your husband's credit is it
will have a foreclosure on it but they
will not chase you to owe them another
ten twenty fifteen thousand dollars he's
going to have a foreclosure on his
record okay there's not anything he can
do to stop it
except sue his mother and he really
can't even effectively do that as long
as she's in bankruptcy so you know she's
not gonna budge he's not gonna make her
budge she's gonna go down and he's gonna
get foreclosed on so hopefully it's an
FHA loan and that would go ahead and
call the lender and find that out and
then just not worry about any more I
wouldn't pay a dime on it I wouldn't
think about it again it's going to go
down
y'all don't need she's not gonna deed
the property over to you which will be
the only other way you could handle it
and you could then you could sell it to
avoid a foreclosure right but I assume
it's got as much Oh Donna this it's
worth probably doesn't it yeah I think
they only own the house first no no
maybe seven months before they were
behind on payment yeah how long has she
been in the chapter thirteen less than a
year
yeah okay yeah my prediction is she
won't make it another year that's my
prediction and I'm sorry I wish I wasn't
right but I'm right so if he could take
that if she would give him the house
back or she would agree to sell it they
could sell it to avoid this foreclosure
but I'm not writing a check for a dime
into this thing if I'm you guys not a
dime okay it's just gonna go down and
she's just gonna have to find her place
to live and it was a bad deal everybody
that did this deal was stupid the
mortgage company your husband and his
mother it was just a dumb dumb thing to
do all the way around so it's sad I'm so
sorry you guys are facing this now your
worst case scenario is it's not an FHA
that it is a VA or conventional I'm
almost positive either one of them
veterans no it's not a VA then okay so
it's probably either an FHA or a Fannie
Mae Fannie Mae may come after him for
the difference and so if they sell the
house for $200,000 after foreclosure and
they owed two and a quarter they're
going to come knocking on your door 125
thousand bucks you can settle that for
10 20 cents on the dollar at the time if
it comes up after a year or two after
the foreclosure but I'm not worrying
about any of that today okay I would
keep my finger on the pulse of it just
to know what's going on but I'm not
gonna I'm not fretting I'm not gonna
worry about it's not gonna cost you any
cash for three to five years at the
worst-case scenario best-case scenario
it's not gonna cost you any cash at all
but in no case as your husband going to
get out unscathed
his credit is dinged every time she pays
a payment late and his credit is dinged
again when she gets he gets foreclosed
on because he's a cosigner
this is why we tell people to never
cosign as these situations like this is
heartbreaking so you guys go yeah you
guys go live your budget work your baby
steps get yourself out of that get
yourself in a good position just to
protect your family and maybe somewhere
down the road you've got some extra
wealth and maybe you want to help Mom in
some regard if she behaves but probably
not okay all right is that okay keep
working those baby steps here yeah just
keep working them on your side don't
spend a lot of emotional or spiritual
energy fretting about this or being
angry at her your husband signed up for
it too okay thank you very much she's
obviously being an obstinate jerk but
there's just no sense and I'd spend all
my time and energy if I were you on your
family and I'm changing your family tree
so this never happens again